hey how's it going Bryson my name is Pat
we're playing lake Moo candy K oh my god
I forgot about yeah yeah yeah get in the
car everyone get in the car we're
stunned
okay well let's keep going with that the
ice cream lover she wants her ice cream
and she wants it now what this is
chocolate
there we go vanilla Lord vanilla
ah [ __ ] me ice cream why didn't you warn
me Oh excellent
Oh God [ __ ] me I'm sitting on am I
sitting on the toilet
Maurice attempt yet yes let's that we
have to do everything perfect
to do this we're gonna do this together
present we're all in this together
what sing it with me once all God once
we know what we got and you can can we I
know oh my god chickens the question
that we've all wondering is if we can
use some unki for anything oh god [ __ ]
[ __ ] sake [ __ ] sake leg leg
oh my god I can use leg as a weapon okay
we have one of the gasoline now we just
we're stuck fabulous okay that's fine
that's fine sometimes in life you get
stuck and you think to yourself oh boy
what am I going to do now let's go into
slaughterhouse it'll be fine
it's just a slaughterhouse it's not like
ah check that back
I took everything I ever said back let's
not trip the alarm it's watching is in
good old porn I could respect that okay
let's take the thing okay that's fine
that's also fine
oh god that's terrifying
okay that's fine that's all right all
right all right all right all right all
right you know what look at this it is
progress but you didn't think that [ __ ]
got a [ __ ] shotgun now I'm gonna [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up like a [ __ ] your mother
I'm so sorry I didn't [ __ ] your mother I
owe her [ __ ] bring out God
all right well he went to space it's
fine as I like to say if [ __ ] like to
go to space then let them go to space
okay that just happened
I just got [ __ ] shot in the ass
excuse me okay look this is just just
what I wanted the [ __ ] is wrong with
everyone shut up
shotgun [ __ ]
that is a no-no so the rat comes when
the door man I am this is hard I don't
understand asking anyone does anyone
want some [ __ ] ice cream it went to
my screen bay we get
yeah we're [ __ ] good look at this
[ __ ] oh god okay okay we're fine eat
dicks and die [ __ ] I'm taking with me
oh we can drive fabulous I'm outta here
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you on never look I got damnit
alright let's find some more gas sunmo
gas in my ass some more gas in my ass
huh nothing weird going on there at all
okay how do we [ __ ] them up yeah I think
how do you guys do that I don't know how
stop stop I swear to god oh my god I'm
so pissed super annoying super you're
super annoying oh my god you uh chrome
stopped working normal that I need crop
funny helveta jävla Paulo Vista so good
do you think I give a [ __ ] the chrome
stopped working when I'm not in [ __ ]
using it
yeah pays a [ __ ] [ __ ] alright don't
worry no problem this is just attempt
number 458 trying to pull up here I'm
wearing my cowboy boots on today ok no
no no that's fine that's fine I wanted
to do that you see now I can do this I
hate everyone all right monkey I'm sorry
but it looks like I will have to
sacrifice you to Lord and mighty claw
just got to [ __ ] ok this is fine this is
fine this is just that's part that's
that's this perfect unity
you
fantastic great great great just [ __ ]
great just so [ __ ] good so [ __ ]
good this is just what I need it just
what I need
goddamnit there's two of them how did
that go through him what's the actual
[ __ ] face ah trap fantastic
[ __ ] the shed [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey just don't it